Peter Desberg, co-author of Now That’s Funny:
Should we be choreographing our leg thing
here?
Jeffrey Davis, co-author of Now That’s Funny:
Well, I like to do this.
Film Courage: Well, you know…you are each
your own person…even though you share sort
of one mind for the writing, you are each
your own person.
Peter: We do?
Jeffrey: Who says we share the same mind?
Peter: Whose mind are we sharing?
Jeffrey: Neither of ours.
Peter: If I were sharing his mind, you’d
see the perforations.
Film Courage: Well, you are your own people
for the sake of this interview so you can
each do whatever you want.
We’ll start with you then Jeffrey.
How did you break into television?
Jeffrey: Well…let’s see…a lot of this
is going to get cut, right?
Peter: Edited.
Jeffrey: Edited?
Film Courage: Um…I think as long as there
are no names that are implicated, I think
everything will be okay.
Jeffrey: Oh, okay.
Well the way I broke into TV is that my father,
my uncle, my first stepmother, my stepfather
were all in the industry.
So I grew up around it and that meant I knew
pretty much knew everybody and not a single
one of them gave me a job (at first).
Peter laughs at my jokes [Jeffrey nudges Peter].
My first job was delivering call sheets at
Paramount, which of course we don’t do anymore
because everything is sent by email.
Then one of my dad’s writing partners was
a guy named Al Levitt (his real name was Al
Levitt) he was blacklisted (he and his wife
were blacklisted) and they wrote under the
name of Tom and Helen August.
And many years later when the blacklist was
over and my dad was greylisted which meant
you were associated with…yeah I don’t
think I’ve told this story before…if you
were greylisted you were at some point going
to be called before The Committee.
But his friends (The Levitt’s) after the
blacklist was over, they were working on an
(boy this is a long story) they were working
on an Aaron Spelling show.
It was the period when Love Boat was on (which
I later worked on) and Fantasy Island and
they wanted to do a show called…I think
Aaron had sold a show called Paradise Hotel.
And in those days they would give you the
pilot script and 6 episodes and then they
would decide if they were going to shoot it.
They didn’t always shoot the pilot.
So they gave me a script.
I had never written television before.
I think I tried to write a screenplay in college
(not grad school) because I was going to be
the Great American Novelist.
And I got paid for it, I got in the Writer’s
Guild and then ABC decided not to make the
show.
And that was my first job.
And then I met my writing partner (my long-term
writing partner) who I had a lot in common
with because her great uncles and her grandfather
were The Fleischer Brothers.
So Popeye, Betty Boop, Out of the Inkwell
and we worked together 12 years and that’s
the partnership that Hollywood likes the best
is male-female partners.
Next they like partners because they are getting
two minds for the price of one.
Film Courage: And so are we today.
Jeffrey: So that’s sort of my background,
but I was around it all my life…and boy
that was long-winded even by my standards.
You can cut around it I’m sure.
Film Courage: Peter for you…joke writer…when
did you begin?
Or maybe that wasn’t the first thing you
did?
Jeffrey: Yesterday.
Peter: Well, surprisingly I came in from the
academic side and started studying the psychology
of humor and started doing research in it
and then I took some courses in comedy writing,
stand up and got more and more immersed.
And next thing you know, I was writing joke
books.
We wrote a few kid joke books, they sold pretty
well.
And then started writing adult joke books
(fun stuff)…not as long or as good as Jeffrey’s
story.
Jeffrey: Certainly not as long.
Film Courage: You also balance your career
moonlighting as a therapist or a psychologist?
Peter: Well, I started out as a research psychologist,
later switched over to (or added) clinical
psychology to where…actually here’s another
in a series of boring stories since Jeffrey
started the tradition.
I developed a course called Instructional
Humor which was a course for public speakers
for how to get their point across and in doing
that I watched how nervous students would
get when they had to get up and deliver anything
is how I got interested in stage fright.
Film Courage: Okay interesting.
Is there room for jokes when you are doing
clinical research amongst the colleagues?
Or that’s where you got your material from?
Peter: Interestingly, stories help people
remember things.
When I was a professor anything I wanted students
to remember I had to come up with a clever
or funny example or a clever or funny story
to get them to remember the concept.
Otherwise…[imitates a bird flying away].
It’s a survival skill.
The way the mind works, it remembers stories
better than facts.
Jeffrey: That explains so much about history
and science for me.
Not really.
Sorry.
Film Courage: Have either of you tried stand-up?
I think I remember you saying that you had?
Jeffrey: Yes.
My first writing partner Julie Fleischer had
been in…I don’t know…you guys came here
too late but the Kentucky Fried Theater was
sort of the thing of the moment and they did
improv shows which were scripted actually
I found out later and then they would do some
improv with the audience.
And their parents went on and made AIRPLANE
later (Zucker, Abraham and Zucker).
They were cousins and brothers.
Peter: The Zucker Brothers.
Jeffrey: And she went to work for them and
had long been an actress when I met her.
She had been an actress and a stand-up and
one night she did convince me to go to The
Comedy Store and I…it was really bad.
Film Courage: It was a Jan Brady moment?
Jeffrey: People were asking for their money
back.
It doesn’t get worse than that.
I wanted to be an actor when I was in high
school.
I don’t think I’ve told you this story?
I think I was doing Inherit The Wind which
you know is the two main characters are based
on William Jennings Bryan and Clarence Darrow
and the both have to remember these long speeches
and I had to memorize the speech from The
Bible and I went out halfway through it and
the drama teacher said “Maybe not?”
So I think I became a writer…writers are
very often people who fail at everything else
so that’s been my experience, you know.
I did try a lot of other things.
Film Courage: Or maybe they’re comfortable
in their whole element though?
That’s a whole other topic.
Jeffrey: Despite the fact that I love to be
around people, I love being alone in a room
and I think you have to have that, too.
Peter is much more sociable than I am.
He’s good in crowds.
Peter: But I remember taking a stand-up class
and the first day the instructor got up and
said “Comedy is a really aggressive art
form.
And if you can’t take it, get out!”
Which kind of stuck with me and the couple
times I got up there and I tried it I said
“Hmmm, harder than it look on TV.”
But my wife plays the accordion and we play
in a group together and I get to write the
songs in genre with accordion plays in an
attempt to make them funny.
And I get to do all the patter between there
which satisfies my need to do that.
Film Courage: Okay, but again you feel comfortable
behind a typewriter or a computer is it?
Peter: As we say in Hollywood, I go both ways.
Jeffrey: He’s been waiting all week to say
that.
Film Courage: Yes…I’m not sure how to
answer that?
Jeffrey: Don’t even try.
Take some advice.